how does adding more Lanes cause more
traffic take a city and a suburb between
them is a two-lane road a bike path and
a train line most people commute by bike
or train the two-lane road is jammed
every day so the city widens it to four
lanes the road is no longer jammed now
Karen and her 50 friends can all take
their kids to school by car now a
hundred rail commuters can drive so they
aren't dependent on train schedules now
20 cyclists can drive because it's
faster the four-lane road becomes jammed
so the city widens it to six Lanes the
road is no longer jammed now 20
commuters can drive any company fuel
allowance instead of riding a bike now a
hundred rail commuters can drive so they
aren't dependent on train schedules Now
50 high school students can drive
instead of bike or train because it's
faster due to lower ridership and
revenue the train line Cuts connections
schedules become infrequent and
impractical so 200 rail commuters switch
from train to car the six lane road is
jammed every day so the city wind is it
to eight lanes and so on until you have
the KT freeway and this is how adding
more Lanes only causes more traffic